starting off this hour is gonna be
Cassie in Buffalo New York hey Cassie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show what's
up in your world thank you
I was wondering and you always hear
people say get a job under the table is
there a benefit to that or is it better
to get a job on the books and claim
everything that's so that you can best
into an IRA who are people like you here
people like when you're working and
things only if you get the job under the
table gonna shop it on the table but
isn't it better to get a job on the
books and be able to invest your money
yeah let's just start with this basic
idea okay in the United States of
America we have a federal law that
charges us an income tax on our income
to not pay tax on any income that we
have made would be breaking the law okay
did you know that no I do but I'm just
gonna I mean I hear people say to do
this why are people all the time I hear
people say rob banks I hear people say a
lot of stupid but stuff but that doesn't
mean it's a path to success okay so
here's the thing as we have studied for
instance Tom Stanley who did the book
millionaire next door to another book
called the millionaire mind and in that
book he studied deck of millionaires
people with ten million dollars or more
you know what their number one
correlating what the number one
statistical correlation among all the
deck of millionaires was it was
unbelievable fanatical levels of
integrity people with integrity have a
very high tendency towards success it is
a necessary building block to becoming
successful and so I pay taxes I get paid
cash for a lot of different things that
we do here people come up at the you
know book tables and they pay us cash
for books it would be very easy to not
report all of our cash transactions I
report every single dime
not because I'm patriotic and I think
the income tax system is just I'm sure
it's in just I
just filled out the forms this morning
and I'm still pissed so it's
unbelievably unjust unjust it's a
horrible system it's ridiculous that I
pay the taxes that I pay absolutely
moronic but I pay every penny not
because it's about taxes and not because
it's about the federal government or my
belief in them as a system but it's
because my integrity is on the line and
so regardless of whether you can report
it or not I would challenge you to say
your integrity is on the line let's just
start with that and my argument to them
but I did want to invest my money for
the long run for my future and they were
saying well the government's going to
charge you 30% and what if you only make
five percent on your IRAs and they said
well in the long run I wouldn't rolls
over isn't that going to be more of an
official in the long run well what I'm
saying I'm telling you Trump's
everything here Trump is a trump card
that I just said over all that because
if you don't have integrity you're going
to struggle to be successful it's not
about percentages okay it's about
telling the truth and doing the right
thing and abiding by the law and if you
run around your whole life trying to be
a scam artist you're gonna die a broke
scam artist and so that's what these
people you're running with none of these
people you're talking to that have these
ridiculous opinions are
multimillionaires they're all losers
Mary Kay they're all losers and so you
don't want to model your life after
losers and so you know on the short term
you know to start with they're not
paying 30% anything okay if you got two
kids and your household income is thirty
thousand dollars or less you don't pay
federal income tax at all anyway even if
you report it all as a matter of fact if
you file you get money from the
government called a Earned Income Tax
Credit okay you know you get money from
the government even though you didn't
pay anything in and so they're missing
out because they're so stupid to start
with but aside from that it's just a
lack of integrity and so model your life
after people that are noble people that
have a high calling on their life people
that are successful people that end up
where you want to end up you ever mean
an old person and go I want to be them
when I grow up
and I've got some old people that I've
met some old people you well you thank
you I'm not that old shut up but Oh
start the call when I'm out shopping
today with Dave Ramsey buy that I'm like
Nick stuff yeah be quiet conscience yeah
you know I mean I I've met some old
people I don't want to be like them when
I grow up they're old they're mean
they're angry they're bitter and they're
broke I've met them too and so you just
got to decide who where you're going and
what your goals are and let that kind of
thing set your table for you and
sometimes in the short term the math
doesn't work actually in this situation
you're talking about the math doesn't
work to your benefit to go ahead and you
know not only be on the books but you
actually file your tax returns you know
if you're not making some pretty serious
money you need to keep in mind 49% of
Americans less you're paid zero federal
income tax so this idea that one of
these characters you're talking to is
actually in the 30 percent tax bracket
is probably statistically impossible so
just don't meet people they're making
$100,000 a year run around you one let's
do everything off the books you know
it's just not me so a few coke dealers
maybe but other than that I mean it's
the only reason they want off the books
is for other reasons but there you go so
integrity integrity is important it's
more important than the math because
it'll lead you into the math not the
math into the integrity